there's quidditch there's footage for  muggles and now there's Quidditch for  Space Marines thanks to xbox live user  XX hug a bear XX using the forge tools  in halo 5 guardians huggy bear has  recreated the Quidditch field from the  Harry Potter universe it basically plays  out like a game of Grifball this means  there is only one ball in play and there  isn't a game-ending golden snitch or a  secret position but who knows this could  be updated in the future to better match  the magical sport the map is called  Quidditch arena and it can be found on  x.x hug a bear xx's halo 5 profile page  before this other halo 5 players created  a Star Wars pod racing mode and a custom  game type that involved running up a  hill during an avalanche sounds like fun  I imagine this won't be the last  interesting creation we see in Halo 5 so  for more stay tuned to gamespot